this is what voting looks like during a
pandemic
masks and physical distancing despite a
surge in coronavirus cases across
myanmar
voters were eager with some arriving
even before polling stations had opened
even though the kovid 19 outbreak seems
really bad right now
i had made up my mind that i must vote
in this election
all my family members have voted too
the national league for democracy or nld
led by aung san tsuchi
is widely expected to win a second term
while her international reputation has
suffered
because of her failure to speak up for
the rohingya after they were targeted in
a violent military crackdown in 2017
she remains hugely popular at home
but the nld's margin of victory is
expected to be smaller this time
economic growth has fallen short of
expectations and ethnic conflicts
persist in the country
the polls have been described as
fundamentally flawed
by rights group human rights watch more
than one and a half million people
mostly ethnic minorities won't be able
to vote
voting has been cancelled in more than
50 townships
in areas the election commission says
are troubled by unrest
some ethnic political parties have
accused the election commission
of trying to block votes in
constituencies dominated by ethnic
parties
most of the rohingya minority are also
excluded having been stripped of their
citizenship
and rights throughout the years and
whichever party wins
it'll have to share power with the
military which is guaranteed 25 percent
of the seats in parliament
enough to block constitutional changes
but despite the challenges
voters are optimistic
i think this election is very important
and everyone who is already 18
should vote because one vote can change
the result so everyone should vote
regardless of which party they support
the nld's main opponent in this election
as it was in the last
is the military-backed union solidarity
and development party
florence louis al jazeera